hello my name's Rose lovely to meet you
I am from New Zealand but I don't want
to talk about it asking I I've come here
tonight dress as a necktie thank you
very much I tried to dress up for this
tonight but I'm I kinda I don't know if
right now that because I think
unfortunately this outfit sort of teamed
with the rest of my aesthetic and makes
me more look like a character in a
romantic comedy who was only there to
provide exposition to the plot you don't
know me you know like one office worker
character at the very beginning of the
film who would just be like well look
who just walked in its Marcus Samson
heir to the biggest shipping company in
the northern hemisphere notorious
bachelor he says he's waiting for the
right lady to settle down with well good
luck to whoever she is anyway I'm off
and I probably won't see you to the end
of the film possibly in a large group
scene where I have no lines goodbye
goodbye look it I do love having curly
hair I love it but I have to say I heard
a leaf in it three days ago and I have
yet to locate it myself I'm a straight
woman by trade it's me it's absolutely
devastating to be honest because it's
the it's the worst of all of them it's
the worst gender sexuality combination I
think you can get right it's the one
that kind of reflects the poorest
decision-making skills out there doesn't
it because what it means to be a
straight woman what that means is that
given all of the options in the world we
still win for dudes yeah it'll be a
straight woman oh my god tough kick
tough kick for the ladies
turns out you boys you know good you
know good congratulations are you didn't
nearly get away with that so close oh we
got you in the end you know straight
male friends because I am an ally and
they say to me they're like that it's
quite hard to defend being like a
straight man at a time like this do you
know what's harder being a straight
woman given what we know about you now
okay do you know what it feels like to
bits are still like dudes and 20:19 it's
oh it almost feels like trying to
recommend a restaurant that has given
you food poisoning eight times okay you
tell your friends to go you're like no
no no just go just make up your own mind
okay they're great they're great not all
restaurants okay don't go online don't
go on Yelp okay just make up your own
mind right but I do I still love me and
I love to kiss him
oh yeah I've kissed nine men in my life
and they're all here tonight coming our
boy
imagine that that'd be quite cool if we
could just see them again but I have and
I thought nine means single-digit single
digits for the gal pretty good I thought
that was an okay number but it is
surprising a little surprisingly low
surprisingly league is not a word right
it is surprisingly low considering the
fact that I've literally never rejected
anyone in my life I run a very open home
policy when it comes to that sort of
stuff my a no shoes on shoes off that's
fine you know leave your name and number
if you're interested and I think though
I love me and I think my problem though
is that I think I'm so I'm very easily
impressed by men okay my standards are
alarmingly low that's a quote it's a
problem because I think I'm like if a
man can show a moderate level of skill
and literally anything sign me up
honest to god my guy if a man can might
fix a flat tire a man like this I see
like Amendola leaf blowing or if a guy
can fold a fitted bedsheet thick
bellissimo you know I mean I I genuinely
think that men with their lives together
could be quite a popular porn category
I'd be naked go off you should email
someone about that right that's true and
I I do think that straightness being me
being straight is purely a symptom of
low self-esteem which is true and I have
low self-esteem I'm fine with that I
think I've got like the perfect level of
self-confidence as an adult woman right
and that confidence is it's very
specific but some of you might know what
I'm talking about I have the confidence
to measure a length between the two tips
of my index fingers and then travel with
that measurement to the other side of a
room and believe that they will be at
all accurate at the end right
Thank You nays I feel like my confidence
wildly fluctuates throughout the month
right and I know this I know this
because I've got I recently just got a
period tracking app I love it everyone
should get it even if you don't get a
period as players buddy good use it as a
calendar I don't know but I I love my
period tracking app I do have one
problem weather and that is that
sometimes when I am updating it I do
almost feel like I'm writing some sort
of entry into like a wartime Journal of
sorts you don't anything with the
language you have to use maybe like day
five still bleeding I miss my wife so
much
[Applause]